imagine if we could collect energy out
of thin air and I mean it quite
literally you know how you were taught
that a vacuum is nothing but empty space
well that isn't exactly true at least in
the world of quantum mechanics if you
dive deeper below the level of molecules
atoms electrons and protons and into the
world of the tiniest subatomic particles
like quarks you'll see that even the
vacuum of space can never be truly empty
it's filled with particles that randomly
pop in and out of existence but the
exciting thing about these fluctuating
particles is that they generate energy
that we could hypothetically put to good
use
how could we harness this vacuum energy
how would teeny a source of unlimited
power change us and why could this be
dangerous for the planet this is what if
and here's what would happen if we
harnessed zero-point energy
don't be spooked by its complex name
zero-point energy is simply the vacuum
energy we just talked about and
according to calculations in quantum
field theory the vacuum of space holds
an infinite amount of it if we can find
a way to use it just a cup full of this
energy might hold enough power to boil
all the Earth's oceans so where would we
start in quantum mechanics things behave
differently from how they would in
classical physics for example you can't
know where a particle is until you
observe it what's more the more
accurately you determine the position of
the particle the less accurately you can
determine its momentum it's called the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle and it
applies to particle duration and energy
as well a still with me good because
we're just getting to the cool part what
this uncertainty principle tells us is
that zero-point energy exists we just
need to find a way to collect it how
would we do that the vacuum of space is
really cold right but it's not the
absolute zero kind of cold
more like 2.7 Kelvin to transfer
zero-point energy you'd simply need a
colder source to receive that energy the
problem is it's not possible as far as
our technology goes we can't pull the
energy out of nowhere unless we could
reduce the vacuum energy in a region of
space first according to the second law
of thermodynamics the vacuum would try
to fill in the gap and that's where we
could interfere and ko
the zero-point energy but this method
wouldn't be that effective because we'd
spend more energy trying to extract the
zero-point energy I know it seems like a
dead end but let's do what we usually do
in the case when the existing technology
hasn't caught up yet let's fast forward
into the future where all the extraction
issues are resolved and where everything
is powered by zero-point energy
now what unlimited energy would mean
free or almost free energy we'd have
free public transportation and we will
all Drive electric cars everyone
including developing countries would
have access to cutting-edge technology
and to the internet non renewable energy
sources would be a thing of the past
even the renewable sources we use today
would be obsolete why would we need
solar energy Barmes if we could automate
the extraction of unlimited zero-point
energy and never need to worry about
power again but as with all things we
have in excess we could start over using
the energy to the planet might be free
of emissions from fossil fuels but it
doesn't mean that there would be no new
threats from energy consumption we'd
need our governments to regulate how we
use all that energy maybe it would be a
good idea to focus on exploring space
powered by the infinite amounts of
zero-point energy
we'd be able to go across the solar
system in a matter of hours we could
start mining asteroids and terraforming
other planets and maybe one day we
decide to relocate humanity altogether
but that's a story for another what if